[Music]
our new and glorious dawn breaks over
the Middle East we're rigorous American
bombing campaigns have blasted the
region into a friendly golf course of
democracy it's all a part of America's
comprehensive methodically planned
foreign policy strategy let's look back
at our nation's glorious adventures in
intervention a success story 1953 the
United States topples the democratically
elected government of Iran and installs
a king favourable to our oil interests
the charr likes America
ensuring that our nations will be
friends forever in 1979 Iran outs the
Shah which America had helpfully
installed and is inexplicably
distrustful of the United States
meddling in its affairs but don't worry
when Iraq and Iran go to war a year
later President Reagan provides aid to
America's good friend Saddam Hussein
thus ensuring peaceful relations with
Iraq forever
during the Cold War Islamist fighters in
Afghanistan square off against the
godless Soviets America aids a group of
staunch anti Russians called the
Mujahideen including an energetic young
man named Osama bin Laden thus ensuring
a beneficial relationship between the
United States and Afghanistan forever in
1991 America goes to war with Iraq's
evil dictator Saddam Hussein who
illegally occupied Kuwait after a brief
period of vigorous bombing President
Bush declares victory thus ensuring that
America need never returned to Iraq
forever in 2001 the United States
declares war on the Taliban for
shielding evil terrorist mastermind
Osama bin Laden we may never know how
Afghanistan's ultra-conservative jihadis
government came to power or from where
they got their guns but we do know that
America's ongoing presence ensures a
lasting peace with a grateful people
forever
in 2003 President George W Bush house
evil strongman dictator Saddam Hussein
thus ensuring a democratic prosperous
Iraq forever in 2011 President Barack
Obama topples the government an evil
Libyan dictator Muammar Gaddafi thus
ensuring a peaceful Libya forever
especially in Benghazi forever in 2016
Nobel Peace Prize winner President Obama
drops over 26,000 bombs across seven
different nations thus ensuring blah
blah blah forever in 2017 Bashar
al-assad unleashes chemical weapons in
Syria provoking the wrath of new US
president Donald Trump Trump by as a
symbolic fuselage of missiles at Syria
thus solving the Assad problem forever
a year later Bashar al-assad unleashes
chemical weapons again in Syria after
apparently failing to notice the
previous bombing the direct threat to
American national defense which Syria
poses is self-evident and president
Trump authorizes a new strike against
the regime thus ensuring American safety
forever today's scientists believe the
Middle East is one strategic bombing
away from a lasting peace president
Trump's my recycle punch in Syria could
be that penultimate explosion the region
so clearly needs bring the United States
to turn her attention to other trouble
spots around the globe and there to
enforce an aggressive peace
[Music]